One thing we must do as a nation is welcome
our returning citizens back to the community.
But we need to make sure that when they come
back that they’re ready to do so.
You know, nationally that over 2/3 of those
who leave prisons actually return within three
years?
That’s a big challenge.
One way to address that is to invest in them
before they leave.
I had a chance to visit the Prison Entrepreneurship
Program in Texas where the recidivism rate
is only seven percent.
And they do four things.
Number one, there’s a course focused on
character development.
Number two, there’s a course focused on
entrepreneurship.
Number three, there’s a business plan competition.
And number four, once you leave there are
support services they provide.
I think the program is a step in the right
direction.
Once you teach someone who’s returning home
how to take care of themselves, they can take
care of themselves, their family, and ultimately
the nation.
By investing in people and investing in human
dignity, we invest in parents, we invest in
human assets, but more importantly, we make
a safe and sound nation of ourselves.
So what do you think can be done to help returning
citizens from prison?
Also tell us what ideas AEI scholars should
focus on in 60 seconds.